escenas de personas están reunidas cerca
de este camión para recoger agua potable
y alimentos el gerson ciudad ucraniana
recientemente retomada a los rusos los
voluntarios comienzan a distribuir la
ayuda humanitaria y es con expresiones
de gratitud y lemas como Gloria a
Ucrania que los residentes les dieron la
bienvenida gracias por venir les
estábamos esperando los voluntarios
prepararon unos 600 paquetes con
cereales aceite conservas y otros
productos que distribuyeron en
diferentes partes de personas
como pueden ver la gente está buscando
ahora mucha comida porque aquí no había
nada pero hay una buena noticia algunos
dicen que todavía tienen gas esto es
bueno así podrán sobrevivir al invierno
las organizaciones de ayuda humanitaria
tienen previsto llevar aún más ayuda a
la ciudad en unos días un apoyo más que
bienvenido y a que las autoridades
describen la situación en la ciudad como
grave debido a la falta de agua
medicamentos y pan Las tropas ucranianas
llegaron al centro de gerson después de
que Rusia abandonara la capital regional
que capturó en marzo la reconquista de
gerson por parte de los ucranianos es un
gran revés para Moscú las ciudades la
capital de una región que Rusia había
anexionado y la única de importancia que
había logrado capturar